Have you ever sat down to take a test and
completely forgotten what you had studied,
or opened your fridge and not
remembered what you came to get?
Quite often, we only remember these things once
we return to the place where we studied, or to
where we had the initial craving for that snack.
These experiences are so common that psychologists
have studied them for years, and attribute them
to something called “context-dependent memory.”
What is context-dependent memory, and how does
it work? To understand, let’s first have a look
at how memories are formed. This usually happens
in three stages, encoding, storage, and retrieval.
When you learn something new or have a new
experience -- say, you meet someone at a
party -- your brain takes this information
-- the person’s face, the sound of their
voice -- and transforms it into a memory code, a
pattern of activity in a network of nerve cells.
This is known as encoding. The encoded memories
are temporarily stored in short-term memory,
and if you call upon them enough, they can
get transferred to more permanent storage
called long-term memory, from where they can
be recalled whenever you need to use them.
This process of accessing information from
long-term memory is known as retrieval.
The interesting thing about forming memories
is that your brain encodes and stores not only
the information that you are actively focused on
but also some of the contextual information from
your surroundings. Things you might overlook
-- like the music playing in the background,
a subtle aroma in the room, or the physical layout
of the space -- are encoded in addition to your
new friend’s face and name. This link, between
the context and the thing you want to remember,
is the basis for context-dependent memory. When
you find yourself struggling to remember the
name of your dance partner, listening to
the song that you danced to or revisiting
the location of the party might help you
remember. If the context during retrieval
is similar to the context during encoding, you
are much more likely to recall the memory.
The idea of context-dependent memory is not
only intuitive, it has also been scientifically
supported with experimental data. In one of the
classic studies on context-dependent memory,
researchers asked two groups of divers to memorize
a list of words in two different contexts.
One group memorized the words
while they were underwater,
and the other group did this on land.
After the words had been memorized,
the researchers asked half the divers to recall
the words in their original learning context,
and the other half to recall the words in the
context where they did not learn the words.
The researchers found that words learned
underwater were best recalled underwater,
and vice versa. Other studies have
also shown that internal states and
moods -- such as the feeling of hunger, happiness
or being caffeinated at the time of memory
encoding -- can help in the contextualization
of memory and operate as the retrieval cue.
So what affects the strength of a
context-dependent memory? Some of the factors
that enhance context-dependent memory at the time
of encoding are the richness of the context -- if
a high number of cues stimulate many different
senses, the memory will be better contextualized;
the uniqueness of the context -- say the high
volume of the music playing; and the level
of attention you pay to small details in your
surroundings. Among factors that interfere with
forming a strong context-dependent memory are high
stress levels or fatigue at the time of encoding,
since these things decrease your
attentiveness to contextual details.
Now that you know how a specific smell, sound, or
feeling can influence the way you form and recall
memories, you can try to use context-dependent
memory to your advantage. The next time you are
preparing for a test, try studying in a similar
environment to the one you will take your test in.
And if you forget what you wanted from the
fridge, try revisiting the place where you first
thought about what snack you wanted. Most likely,
you’ll find the answers that you knew all along!